[Musique]
on a initié l inspire d'abord un
terrible sentiment de vertige mais ces
pentes de saut à ski font la fierté de
courchevel en savoie d'autant qu'elles
sont rares et particulièrement pour les
jeux olympiques ça a toujours été
quelques chose de très coûteux et après
les communes qui organisait et où les
stations qui organisait les compétitions
ne pouvait pas les entretenir et c'est
tombé mais pas ici 30 ans après les jeux
olympiques d'albertville les olympiens
en herbe peuvent toujours s'y entraîner
et compétitionner vous savez une station
de réputation comme celle de courchevel
elle se doit d'avoir des équipements
comme ça on a plein d'équipement plein
d'équipement on a construit un stade de
slalom éclairé pour prendre des coupes
du monde que tout ça d'un à courchevel
une image sportive que le maire préfère
de loin à celle peut-être encore plus
répandue de hauts lieux de loisirs
darchy luxe
au delà des installations sportives des
jeux olympiques d'albertville ont
surtout été un tremplin qui a permis à
la ville et à toute la région de faire
un bond de 20 en avant dans le
développement de ses infrastructures
une autoroute à deux voies la gare de
tgv ça semble aujourd'hui banal et sans
les jeux en 1992 la région n'aurait pas
investi autant dans six transports ça a
vraiment façonné albertville c'est
aujourd'hui pour ça qu albert ville
entre humains est connu de façon
nationale voire internationale puisque
c'est vraiment les jeux qui ont fait ce
qu'ils ont fait exploser cette ville une
ville qui a su moderniser son économie
au passage dit le maire mais qui doit
faire attention de ne pas sombrer dans
la nostalgie
et ça ça coûte de l'argent on peut dire
que c'est un cadeau empoisonné puisque
effectivement il ya un coût mais c'est
un investissement et c'est comme un
andré guillemet la culture c'est on y
met de l'argent ce parce que c'est pas
parce que c'est à perte c'est juste que
c'est un investissement dans la culture
ou dans le sport et c'est comme ça qu'il
faut voir les choses effectivement non
pas comme une commune dette
seul grand témoin physique du passage
des jeux olympiques dans la ville qui
leur a donné son nom il a fallu investir
13 millions d'euros soit plus de 20
millions de dollars pour moderniser la
grande halle olympique
pense que ce serait terrible d'abord un
outil qui soit à l'abandon après le
après les jeux olympiques
on apporte des prestations en plusieurs
offres à nos habitants comme la
patinoire le mur d escalade des
événements d'une salle de spectacle avec
des événements sportifs culturels et
économiques
les sites répartis dans toute la savoie
qui ont accueilli les athlètes de la
planète entière pour quelques 23 jours
sont presque tous encore aujourd'hui en
activité et s'ils contribuent tous à
l'essor économique de la région il
continue aussi de bénéficier d'argent
public pour rester au sommet de leur
discipline
kilomètre et demi 19 virage c'est ce qui
attend aujourd'hui près de 12000
visiteurs chaque année en quête de
sensations fortes qui passe par la piste
de bobsleigh à la plagne
on reçoit aujourd'hui des clients qui
viennent tout simplement descendre sur
la piste olympique des jeux olympiques
d'albertville et parcourt la même piste
les mêmes virage évidemment vont un
petit peu moins vite puisqu'on a trois
produits qui vont de 80 85 km an jusqu'à
120 km heure pour les plus les plus
sportifs ou ceux qui sont en recherche
de sensations fortes
rassurez vous aucun besoin d'une
expérience ou d'un talent particulier
pour survivre et apprécié la petite
minute et demie que dure la descente dès
le lendemain des jeux les équipements de
la plagne ont été complètement
transformée pour permettre des descentes
automatisés une première dans le monde
les premiers critères était d'avoir un
engin qui soit autoguidés auto freiner
ou un client en barque et soit
complètement on va dire à la découverte
de l'activité sans une obligation que
soin de piloter ou de dax et les roues
de freiner les jeux d'albertville en
laisser dans leur sillage cette envie
cette culture de l'événement et pourquoi
pas dans le ton ici se relancer dans
l'aventuré olympique aujourd'hui on a
pratiquement tous les équipements qu'il
faut on n'est pas obligé de reconstruire
des tremplins on n'est pas obligé de
reconstruire une piste de bob tous ces
équipements qui coûte très très cher au
lisa nos stades sont très bien équipés
et tous horizons albertville 2030 la
région est bien en piste